daniel is with us daniel's in dallas
texas hi daniel how are you
i'm doing well dave thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
um so i'm 35 and i've never been married
uh i met a young lady that i'm thinking
about marrying uh
i have a unique situation i i kind of
have a unique situation that i have a
net worth around a million dollars
and so i kind of have a two-part
question uh what should the conversation
sound like whenever i disclose all this
to her
and then do i need a prenup i know
you've discussed it before but i just
kind of look at your thoughts
yeah um what's our financial situation
do you know
um the only thing we've really ever
talked about is debt and then kind of
savings she's very frugal like she has
an iphone 6
she has money saved in the bank and she
has no debt
paid for car and so on and so forth very
low maintenance that's like half of her
appeal
and i have not disclosed anything to her
other than
i don't have any debt and i'm also
pretty frugal and she can tell like i
drive an old jeep
so um but yeah she's
very down to earth and so i just don't
really know how to
lay it on her without being like hey i
have this money but
i don't want to go buy a brand new audi
or anything yeah
okay well i i what's the million dollar
net worth composed of
yeah it's um some retirement accounts um
uh and then like mutual funds i own some
individual stock
i own a few rental properties in dallas
um well done that's pretty much it
good job how long y'all been dating
uh only six months but i've been dating
for 20 years
and you know they say when you meet the
one you're gonna
know and i'm kind of getting that vibe
from her so that's why i'm
taking it a lot more seriously yeah uh
christy sounds like it's time to talk
about this
yeah and it's interesting because i
think that well let me ask you this
daniel i've got a follow-up question
when you say how should i do it how have
you played it out in your mind like what
fears do you have because i sense that
like there's some hesitation on your
part but i'm not sure what it is
right a friend of mine recently he had a
pretty good size network and it was like
probably about 800 900 000 bucks and
he's going through a nasty divorce and
she's gonna get half of it
and it's like he's telling me man you
really need a prenup and be careful what
you do with girls and i realize that
he's saying that just because he's in
that set of circumstances but the same
time it's making me kind of rethink my
position
and then you know money you never really
fully know somebody and so whenever you
start disclosing information like this
it can be one of those things where you
get turned on your head like oh i
thought i knew this person and now she's
acting completely differently
um so that's kind of where i'm at with
that yeah you can't control how she
reacts
correct and you certainly can't get
married if you haven't disclosed this
so you've got to start talking it sounds
like it's time to talk about it because
you're talking about popping a question
and you feel like you're
you know you're this relationship's
gonna end in marriage so
yeah you definitely gotta start uh
disclosing and talking about it
and you're gonna have the prenup
discussion later you don't have to do it
all in one fell in one you know one sit
down
uh the only time i i used to never
recommend prenups i used to say if you
don't love the person more in your money
that you shouldn't get married and i
changed that
after about a decade of coaching people
because where i ran into
extreme wealth uh which a million
dollars at 35 years old is pretty
extreme
um when i run into large amounts of
wealth
uh i found not that the person that
you're marrying is usually the problem
but if you don't have a prenup as a
boundary the
crazy people in their family come out of
the woodwork
and so uh and if they you know and if
she's if she knows crazy bob's gonna
call
she can just go crazy bob there's a
prenup and i can't do i don't have
access to this
because they if the family starts
finding out or somehow
realizes that that you know she's hit
the gold she's hit a
a gold vein here and and is is
you know going to be set then and and
some bad member toxic member of the
family and most every family has at
least one crazy bob in it right
so um you know so you know it just
brings out the weirdness in other people
more than the
person and um and i don't mind too
i i would probably recommend that over a
period of years that the prenup erode
to nothing like if you've been married
20 years and you're not willing to
uh do that then you gotta you got other
problems in your marriage you're not
willing to do away with the prenup at
that point
but uh this thing of uh you don't want
to
spiritually or relationally get in the
thing where i'm putting
the money as more important than the
relationship
but it's just to keep the weirdness away
right and i was going to ask her during
the discussion be like listen this is
just between you and me
please don't disclose this to anybody
else just trying to try to eliminate
any kind of drama or anything that
happens or someone asking us for money
i really don't want to deal with that
eventually that's going to come up
though
right somewhere sometime somehow
what do you mean well i mean
the chances of you going five years
being married to this girl and her
parents don't know you're a millionaire
is zero
you think so yeah oh i don't know daniel
i think that if she doesn't if it's
y'all's money you get married it's
y'all's money it's ya'll are a team and
you
and she don't want to tell people either
i think it could be yeah
it just that's well they don't not like
you're going in bragging about it on
thanksgiving dinner but it's just gonna
come up
it's just another i mean it's just none
of their business i guess i'm just so
private about that but here's what i
would say
one thing i did want to jump in on this
with the conversation
with your girlfriend um one of the good
things that i think you
can take such encouragement is is her
qualities
financially are already in line with
your values she's not a diva
that's spending all this money and
you're worried she's gonna find out you
got a million dollars and she's gonna be
like
great this i get to go shopping she
doesn't seem like that kind of a woman
and so i think you can approach it with
a with more confidence of knowing that
she's
hopefully not going to be a completely
different person on the other side of
this information
she if she's living frugally now those
are her values with money
i don't think that that would change
drastically um with the amount of money
that you have i would hope you'll find
out but i think you can take some
some encouragement there yeah i would
recommend a prenup for a period of time
and just as a boundary uh more than
anything else
and again it erodes over some period of
time
to where it goes away
and because it does need to become our
money
at some point down the road and you can
treat it like our money and you can
treat the discussion like our money you
don't keep your finances separate after
you get married
you're going to be running things
together and so forth and you know
you uh but what you're trying to protect
against is some bizarre thing happening
with a divorce
or a bizarre family member you know
somehow getting involved i
um privacy is one thing secrecy is
another
so uh be private but you don't have to
be secret i don't have to be ashamed
i don't discuss my net worth with my
family
exactly what it is in terms of i do with
the kids because they're in the estate
plan
but by our extended family you know
sharon's brothers and sisters i mean
they obviously know we have a level of
wealth
but um but they don't they don't have
any idea exactly what it is and i don't
disclose that publicly either
so so that's privacy but i don't have to
also be secret
about it just because i'm afraid that
how everybody's going to react ah
deal with it it's part of who we are and
we're not ashamed of it we've been
successful and
um you know we're not rubbing anybody's
nose in it we're not we're not thumping
our chest at
saying how big a deal we are or
something like that that's not the point
but i'm also not going to hide and you
know oh i can't let anybody find out
because of how they might react
nah yeah that's on them if she flips and
becomes a diva with this information
then that was your acetate
right she's not the one that's right you
know and so it's a good it's a good time
but it sounds like to me the
conversation is getting serious enough
it's time to start talking about this
what do you think
yeah absolutely and it's interesting too
because i think what's cool is on the
other side of this when you have the
conversation
it's going to bring a whole different
level of connection and excitement about
what the future holds
uh for both of you so that's going to be
really fun yeah yeah what was the
teenagers used to call it like when
you're in rachel ortina
define the relationship yes yes dtr dtr
yeah see there's a dad of teen girls
right there formerly a dad of teen girls
a dad of formerly teen girls i'm trying
to get that right yeah
it's stuck with me because i when we
didn't you know we didn't we didn't
define any relationships when i was
growing up
you're there yeah either yes or you
didn't oh well this is the dave ramsey
show